bonjour le fait que mario mercier de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france laurent gbagbo doit
prononcer aujourd'hui à son premier
grand discours un synonyme de retour au
premier plan politique qu'est-ce qu'il
faut attendre de ce discours
il faut attendre une clarification parce
que le parti écrit là où avait été créé
le f pays c'est à l'hôtel d'ivoire que
l'hôtel sofitel hiwar que le fbi avait
été créée dans les années 80 et c'est
dans ce même hôtel que le président
gbagbo lance sa nouvelle formation
politique on attend de lui qu'il
établisse les règles qui ont présidé à
la création et surtout les raisons pour
lesquelles ils de fait la première
raison qui est évidente et qui a été
donné c'est que son parti est légalement
aux mains de pascal affi n'guessan avec
lequel il n'est plus en odeur de
sainteté il crée un nouveau parti
question ses ambitions est ce qu'il
s'agit de préparer la revanche politique
de 2010 c'est à dire se présente à
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 25 est
ce qu'il s'agit de créer aujourd'hui
quelque chose qui montrera qu'il a
encore une existence politique et qui ne
pas enterrer que en revenant de là et il
est encore plus fort que quand on les a
amenés ou alors est ce qu'il s'agit de
mettre les bases de ce désir de
réconciliation tant attendue en côte
d'ivoire c'est assez flou tout ce qu'on
sait c'est que ce sera un party
panafricaniste que ce sera
toujours toute la substance viendra du
pays vu vu que les deux partis
légalement aux mains de pascal fils est
sain et qu'il ne peut pas être récupérés
puisque le choix de laurent gbagbo et de
ne pas aller au combat mais pour le
reste on doit attendre d'eux qu'ils se
prononcent où il voir plus clair après
voir pourquoi parce que vous avez évoqué
afp le front populaire ivoirien
donc pourquoi créer un nouveau parti est
ce qu'il est dans la continuité du front
populaire ivoirien qu'il a quitté en
août dernier quelle stratégie
se dégage avec ce nouveau mouvement est
ce que sait faire du neuf avec du vieux
au final
je pense qu'il est dans la droite ligne
de ce qu'a été la lfp ce qui a été le
combat du fpi sa direction parti de
gauche être un parti de combat politique
qui ne s'avouent pas vaincus quoi qu'il
arrive malgré toutes les crises qu'il a
traversées depuis le 2010 qui marque
menace de saper de gestion de la côte
d'ivoire c'est également un parti qui va
montrer toute la popularité dont
pourraient encore jouir le président
laurent gbagbo au sein des populations
aux ivoiriens ce sont les deux
principaux objectifs est le troisième
qui n'est pas le plus simple c'est aussi
le combat contre la france a fait et
contre les impérialismes dans la partie
francophone du continent africain parce
que on se souvient que en 2010 2011 il
ya quand même eu d'énormes tensions nées
c'était le point d'apogée d'énormes
tensions entre la côte d'ivoire et la
france par rapport à l'ingérence de la
france dans les interventions est ce
qu'il ya des heures ac rendre
prochainement d'ici la présidentielle de
2025 d'un de calais y voit ce nouveau
parti le président actuel alassane
ouattara
je ne pense pas qu'ils à des heures qui
puisse être envisagée entre maintenant
et l'élection de 2025 sachant que
d'ailleurs il ya des élections en 2023
qui sont prévus également tu ne pense
pas qu raiders la preuve la plus
sensible de cela c'est que parmi les
personnes qui sont venues assister à la
création du parti de laurent gbagbo il
ya le délégué du rhdp qui était présent
et donc je ne pense pas que avec cette
embellie qui se présente avec cette
volonté d'afficher la concorde entre les
différents partis politiques de côte
d'ivoire ya un risque de débordement
pour les prochaines échéances
électorales
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de la
popularité de laurent gbagbo 1600
personnes réunies hier lancement de son
nouveau parti il a fait salle comble
mais plus généralement que pensent les
ivoiriens de ce come back après dix ans
d'exil
je traite les avis sont assez partagés
pour le moment on peut pas dire que tous
les ivoiriens sont contents que le
président gbagbo créé un nouveau parti
le fpm partie historique c'est lui qui
s'est battu pour la libéralisation de la
vie politique en côte chinois dont c'est
un parti qui a quand même une histoire
et une grande histoire nationale
aujourd'hui il est empêtré dans des
divisions avec les gbagbo reliait les
pros affi n'guessan une partie aussi pro
simone gbagbo y vais donc toutes ses
chances là aujourd'hui sont éclatés et
ce que l'on attend du parti ce que l'on
attend d'eux laurent gbagbo ce qu'il
arrive à réconcilier les ivoiriens et
cela commence par sa propre famille
politique avant de s'étendre à
l'ensemble de la côte d'ivoire qui a
quand même vécu un problème identitaire
très fort un problème de souverainisme
déformées qui était celui de l'ivoirité
et dans toutes ses blessures la douane
est repensé doivent penser dans la
concorde c'est pour cette lire
aujourd'hui un besoin de réconciliation
et de justice sur le terrain il valait 1
merci louer un camaïeu d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le président du club de l'information
africaine vous étiez en direct de mais
pourquoi